To examine a more realistic problem, let's revisit the problem that we
had in our last lesson. Once again, this is a map of a part of Long Island, and
the problem is to go from Q to the end location here. So I'll call it Q problem.
We'll retrieve from memory the D case, which takes us from this initial
location to this collocation. Clearly, this D case is potentially useful for
addressing the Q problem. But it is not useful as is. The initial location of
the D case is not the same as the initial location of the Q problem. And the end
location of the D case is not the same as the end location of the Q problem.
So we can start with this D case but we need to adapt it. So,
this leads us to the overall process of case-based reasoning. The basic process
of case-based reasoning consists of four steps. The first step is retrieval, and
we already and considered this when we were considering learning by recording
cases. K nearest neighbor is one way of retrieving cases from memory. Once
we have retrieved a case from memory that is delivered to the current problem,
we need to adapt it. For example, in the previous problem we had the D case and
the Q problem. And we needed to adapt the D case into the Q problem.
There are many similar examples. All of us program and
all of us, as computer programmers, sometimes use case-based reasoning.
We are given a new problem to address, and we often look at the design of
a program that we have come across earlier. So there's retrieving a case and
they're adapting a particular design of the old program to solve the new
problem. Once we have adapted the case to meet the requirements of
the new problem, we have a candidate solution for the new problem. With it,
the candidate solution is to be evaluated. For example, in the navigation
problem, when we have a solution of the Q problem, we can evaluate it but
they would actually take us to the end location. We can do a simulation, we
can walk through it. As we walk thought it, we will be able to evaluate whether
the solution actually succeeds in meeting the requirements of the problem. For
the programming problem, once we have a new program that we obtain by
adapting the old program, we can actually run the program to see, whether or
not it will meet the requirements of the new problem. Let us suppose for
a moment that we evaluate a candidate solution and it succeeds. Then,
we could encapsulate the new problem and the new solution into a case, and store
it back into the case memory, so that case memory is constantly increasing.
Notice that this case-based reasoning process unifies memory, reasoning, and
learning. There is a case memory that contains a large number of cases and
that's how we retrieve cases that are relevant to the current problem.
We'll reason when we adapt and
evaluate. And we learn when we store the new case back into the case memory.